- So Jayne we have the pandemic,
we have the Black Lives Matter movement,
there's just a lot of change.
And I think that if we do it right,
it's a change in a great direction,
and I feel like it's been needed
to happen for generations.
But I was just curious how you
were processing everything?
- Well, you know, there's
this thing called Twitter
and it's a double-edged sword.
- Anywhere.
I've laughed, I've never laughed harder,
than when I go through my Twitter feed,
I've never felt as heartbroken,
as when I go through my Twitter feed.
I've never been as angry.
(laughing)
And that's the worst part.
So, it's kind of, that's
where I get my news.
It's been a bit of an addiction for me
and I'm suffering a little bit over it.
So I'm not sure where to put it,
there is just so much
going on and I feel like
I gotta know what it is and
I've gotta understand it.
And I think that that's a healthy thing
because we are at a tipping point,
this is a really tender
moment in our history,
in our nation's history, you know,
are we gonna survive this?
You know, the institutions
and are we gonna tear each other apart?
I mean we're really at a tipping point.
- [Kelly] I agree, I agree.